ever since some popular fantasy show i
forget what it's called something
gotti ever since this show came around
there seems to be a lot of people with a
lot of money trying to make a lot of
more money some might argue that this is
a golden age for science fiction and
fantasy
it's reaching new levels of popularity i
disagree a little bit with that i feel
like game of thrones has made fantasy
appeal more to those who think who look
down upon it the point i'm trying to get
at is fantasy since game of thrones
is
fundamentally
changed it's different
we're not going back to time before then
uh there's like an industrial complex
built around uh fantasy shows right now
from all these streaming services and i
disagree a little bit with people saying
oh golden age for science fiction and
fantasy maybe that's the case in terms
of publishers looking for a fantasy or
the way fantasy is selling it's just a
battle for ips it's a battle for
who has the best brand who has the best
well-known brand in comes our boy
jeffrey bezos who has to be the biggest
and the best and purchase the lord of
the rings ip and property whatever it's
i don't know what you call it so the
trailer comes out and it's of a dubious
quality uh there's i personally don't
know how much you can really ascertain
from a you know
minute long clip if it is even that long
i have a number of hardcore fantasy fans
in my community who uh i figured might
have some thoughts on the general state
of fantasy television fantasy
adaptations i got a lot of responses far
more than i could ever possibly address
in this video but so let's uh dive into
some of the most uh popular takes on
this trend daniel green who is that who
does anyone know who that human is it's
become impossible to be neutral on a
show everyone's expects you to love it
or hate it and having an opinion of that
was fine results on in both sides being
mad at you at least that's my experience
i think that these companies cynically
kind of expect that or want that a lot
of times i mean it stirs up conversation
many expect others to either love it or
hate it and have a strong opinion about
something i think daniel probably gets
these these type of people all the time
who want him to love or hate something
just very mid-tier content it's not
exceptional it's not extremely bad
obviously they pump a lot of money into
these things you hope it'd be better
than it is maybe but it's not something
i pers i can get really angry about and
saying that was fine yeah i mean you're
not supposed to do that especially if
you if you want people to watch anything
you make you can't just say something's
fine do you know what is also fine
politics i bet you're angry now we need
more animated fantasy adaptations look i
think you can do pretty much anything
and in either direction if you're
creative enough if you have the budget
or the skill but would it have as wide
of reach it wouldn't capture the
audiences that live action would it's
unfortunate but i think that's just the
reality i would forgive a lot of the not
so good cgi and the wheel of time if the
storytelling on the show was better
regarding the new lord of the rings show
i just hope it's not a giant wink fest
towards the movies and books and instead
it's a good story that simply justifies
its existence by being well told and
interesting yeah i hope that's the case
too you know i feel like maybe the first
season will be like that and then
they'll get nervous
or run out of ideas in the second season
there's going to be like time traveling
uh frodo cameo feel like all the new
marvel and star wars shows it's like
oh well you know maybe people aren't
really just going to be interested in
this single thing so we gotta throw in a
character at the end am i having deja vu
um also another thing where the a green
chef green chef
add transition green chef is a usda
certified organic company it makes
cooking way easier uh with dinner
options that work around your lifestyle
not the other way around uh plus they do
uh most of the prep for you uh week
after week so you can save time with
less trips to the grocery store here's
me
cooking uh this really good meal for me
and nadia we picked the vegan
meal options uh there's really stuff for
everyone go to green chef dot us and use
code man carrying 130 to get 130 off
plus free shipping on your first box
it's really fun to make there's options
for a variety of lifestyles uh keto and
paleo vegan gluten free vegetarian fast
and fit and mediterranean for those who
simply want a little more balance
plus you can switch up your meal options
whenever you're ready to try a new way
to eat it was exciting to see it seeing
it all come together and it was really
convenient having most of what you need
just in a brown paper bag
i have to say it was
really good seriously uh so go to green
chef us and use code mancaring130 to get
130 off plus free shipping on your first
box yeah so uh anyways thanks thank you
green chef for sponsoring this video
yeah all right well back to it honestly
i'm at this point of pessimism that a
ridiculously terrible show seems like a
good outcome i don't want a mediocre or
fine lord of the rings show i either
want it to be mind-blowingly good or
unforgettably comedically bad yeah it's
fine like i don't know it is fine but
they're not reaching for the freshest
the newest the cutting edge in fantasy i
think you're gonna find that in
in fantasy books some of the scenes from
the lord of the rings trailer looked
like cut scenes from an unfinished 2010
ea game yeah i don't know what that was
about i really that was released at the
super bowl i think right maybe there was
a crunch and also a lot of these shows
they have huge budgets but they aren't
given enough time i don't understand
giving the wheel of time all this money
and then only letting them do eight
episodes gotta be tough you know i feel
for these people who are putting their
heart and soul into these projects i
don't want them to to fail you know
fantasy adaptations are doing the same
trend we saw in the early 2000s of book
to film except this time it's with
streaming series or whatever this i find
feels like an issue because of the way
large companies are just throwing money
at something to get it out there so that
they could make some profits off of it
no matter the quality of the series even
in the early 2000s many of the big
adaptations were given some degree of
care lord of the rings harry potter
aragon narnia something's popular then
you just have a million things trying to
do the same until it dries up and no and
then it's a
a dead genre i want them to do the
ultimate prequel and finally show us
bilbo's conception
yeah they they don't have the guts to do
that never watched or read anything by
tolkien at all so i can't wait for this
to be my one and only introduction to
middle earth
that's that's good i think if people
want to change the source material as
much as they are they need to make new
content it's starting to feel like
companies just want to attach a popular
name to their own products to ensure
initial buy-in and this is you know this
is the story everyone everyone knows you
have the massive blockbusters the marvel
movies and then you have the small
indies you know and the middle movies uh
and in the middle ground are going away
now there's some of that i think more in
television and streaming just because
these huge companies are willing to
throw so much money at anything coming
their way something like a fantasy show
requires um a high budget maybe requires
is in the right word because game of
thrones set the bar really high in terms
of budget uh and how a fantasy show was
supposed to look i would enjoy these
fantasy shows more if more of them cast
renowned actor don cheadle absolutely
most people who say it looks bad are
blinded the lord of thrones trailer uh
are blinded by nostalgia and compare it
to the movie trilogy which they have
through years of rewatching made out to
be pure uh perfection despite them not
being as they remember i just think
there's nothing like them they're very
unique and they really set a huge trend
i think in some ways i personally think
that the lord of the rings the original
trilogy this is a bit of a tangent but i
think they suffer as a result of the
trends that came after lord of the rings
i'm thinking of the big budget
fantasy
narnia pirates of the caribbean that
were all trying to get the look of lord
of the rings i was watching you know
pirates of the caribbean and narnia
before i was watching lord of the rings
when i finally watched lord of the rings
it didn't feel
as fresh or exciting the reason why i
love the lord of the rings trilogy
because the story is incredible the it's
so well done it there's so much emotion
true you know emotion well written i
think people get too hung up on length
when it comes to adaptations there's
this whole idea now that everything
needs to be adapted as a series or can
only be adapted as a show when a movie
can work really well i'm not gonna read
this whole comment because it's super
long but that point is
great i think so much tv
in general would benefit so much if
we're shorter there you can feel when
something was originally written as a
movie as a feature length thing and then
it was stretched into a mini series on
netflix or something it's just this is
the b plot that we don't need this is
the flashback episode that is
out of place but hey why not i don't
understand how amazon can throw so much
money at something in basic things like
lighting and costume designs so it looks
weird uh happened to wheel of time too
everything just looked flat uh where's
the craftsmanship uh i think there's a
lot of craftsmanship that goes into
these shows i really just don't think
they're i think they're rushed the first
season will be decent but then they'll
completely lose momentum for season two
like countless other streaming shows all
the plot will happen in the first and
final episode and then the middle six
through eight episodes will be the
characters arguing for the sake of
filling time it's abundantly clear that
amazon only wants to capitalize on the
huge success of thor the dark world by
making a show with similar themes and
motifs to those of thor the dark world
if my prediction proves correct however
it will not be anywhere near as good or
perform anywhere near as well as thor
the dark world
the last good true fantasy tv series was
merlin nothing fantasy since has topped
it that's the most correct take here
john hurt as a dragon
man i loved that show lord of the rings
more like board of the rings
i have severe constipation at the moment
so i'd rather not reply yet if that's
okay take your time
uh let's check twitter absolutely lame
and disgustingly horrifying these
current fantasy shows but i haven't
watched any of them it's not dirty
enough i want to see more shows where
the people are filthy i yeah i kind of
honestly please just like rub some dirt
on the cloaks every now and then i'd
really like that i get nervous when a tv
series gets an entire expanded universe
for something that really should have a
concise beginning middle and ending i
think a lot of them want to be this
grand time sink not everything has to be
something you get lost in for
seasons of television need more musical
numbers gallivant i mean gallivant told
some of the best stories in 30 minutes
and had musical numbers in theory this
is great in practice we're learning that
hollywood writers trying to add drama to
story aren't nearly as original as they
think they are yeah yeah i well i it is
built into the blood of uh tv uh and tv
structure it's uh we're trying to keep
you around for the commercial breaks it
doesn't really matter if this is going
anywhere we just need you here from one
moment to the next now that we have
streaming it's different and i think the
shows that really succeed understand
that this old school formula for writing
tv it's still around it's very much
adhered to and i think in a way you
can't even call it tv because tv was
supposed to be a certain thing it's
supposed to be viewed very casually but
tv now it's intensity it's about
intensity is about pulling you in and
keeping you in there but you aren't
watching it passively really you are
really engaged you have to make the
choice to pick it there's so many
options it's got to be something that's
going to engage you and not something
that you're just passively watching it's
just like having a really long movie i
think a lot of them are trying so hard
for those shock factor moments present
in game of thrones that they forget that
those moments only work because game of
thrones took the time to develop and
world build and wasn't just grizzly
character deaths after grizzly character
deaths you can do that for a short while
uh in a story you can just throw
something shocking be like wow you bet
you didn't see that coming that was a
shock right
and then you do it again and again and
again and you just go unless it has real
meaning to the story and makes sense it
just feels like oh well you're just
trying to distract me with something
shiny uh and after a while it just
becomes like all the other noise of the
show twin peaks the return said the bar
impossibly high for fantasy this but
sincerely like twin peaks the return is
so good well we're at the end of this
remarkable thing uh i hope this has been
somewhat entertaining slash enlightening
slash a third thing i promise you i read
every single comment it took me a very
long time thank you for that and for
watching yeah have a good one goodbye
you